tonight we examine concerns by some on
the right about the US Supreme Court
Chief Justice John Roberts was appointed
by a Republican president but some
conservatives are now worried he may be
drifting permanently to the left to
balance the court just last week he
sided with the courts liberal wing in a
pair of cases including a death penalty
appeal something that is occurring with
greater frequency tonight Fox News chief
legal correspondent an anchor of Fox
News at nights shannon bream takes a
look at the Roberts record well you know
some days are better than others the
Chief Justice of the United States first
among equals caught in the political
spotlight he has assiduously tried to
avoid on a range of hot-button issues
John Roberts in recent weeks has sided
with his for more liberal colleagues
including a February vote to block
enforcement of a restrictive Louisiana
law on abortion clinic access just last
week he ruled for a death row inmate
over his right leading colleagues
objections
it's the latest sign the 64 year old
Roberts is hitting the pause button on
the expected conservative full-court
press assured in by President Trump
after nominating justices Neil Gorsuch
and Brett Kavanaugh this is an
incrementalist minimalist strategy
whatever you're hoping for or fearing
and whatever your your preferred area of
law might be this Court is not going to
move with giant steps since November the
Chiefs vote in separate pending appeals
proved decisive a half dozen times on
issues like immigration asylum and
transgenders in the military while these
votes do not yet go to the merits of the
larger issues they signal Roberts shaky
place in the courts middle as the so
called swing justice an unofficial title
he inherited for now when Anthony
Kennedy retired the chief has not
explained why his court this term has
also repeatedly taken a cautious go slow
approach keeping the current docket free
of too many high-profile disputes
including the docket immigration program
Indiana abortion restrictions and LGBT
workplace discrimination court watchers
say it may be a pattern of strategic
avoidance
he's long talked about keeping the
judiciary free of partisan sniping that
reached a fever pitch during the
Kavanagh confirmation people need to
know that we're not doing politics they
need
know that we're doing something
different that we're applying the law
the chief justice's relationship with
President Trump has not been without
friction the two engaged in a public
spat last November after the president
criticized an immigration ruling made by
what he called an Obama judge well in a
statement Roberts strongly defended the
integrity of the federal bench prompting
more Twitter pushback from the president
breath one to watch here China Thanks